[Music]
well i kind of agree with the legal
fentanyl why not life's short george
floyd r.i.p i mean we need more fentanyl
but actually obviously i'm kidding
though because you know my buddy i told
you all this you know i worked for the
show cheaters and i signed an nda so i
can't say too much about it even though
you guys can figure out what i mean by
that but uh i just don't ever get sued
because i'm not supposed to go on the
airwaves and talk you know wait steve
stephen crowder's uh the guy who runs
cheaters no no
bobby goldstein is
an annoying jewish guy but not jewish
people are the best people ever but he
was an annoying one um but bobby
goldstein was so annoying because he
like would always he just just he
promised me to be the host of the show
after the hostess guy clark gable died
of a drug overdose and that's why i
started creating content because when it
came to the time to hire they picked
this like 52 year old dj out of new york
called peter guns so i was like you know
i didn't i didn't fit there wait wait
the round there the rapper peter got the
lord to recompute guns no
uptown baby uptown baby yeah
from new york
i wouldn't be here today if he didn't
take my job it's a job that was promised
to me seriously
well no actually no not [ __ ] him because
it's all worked out okay he yeah he was
honestly he was really nice he he didn't
he didn't fire me you know what i mean
you know he was and i didn't get fired
they wanted me to still produce episodes
but i was like man i'm gonna i'm i'm not
and the guy that works at tutors like
you should do your own podcast and then
that's when i started going to i started
doing my podcast and then like very
quickly i went to a city council meeting
and i spoke seriously like oh you need
to open up blah blah blah and they
looked at me like i'm an idiot then i
started with the first video i did it
didn't really go viral at all but i was
like our mayor johnson i was like you
should go in the game cedar springs
where this drag race was actually i
mentioned that
you should show eric johnson's free
johnson and johnson the gay community
would love the double entendre and like
that like and i called him the first
openly gay mayor of dallas and he has
like a beautiful wife and kids not
really beautiful but you know what i
mean he has a picture
and you know how a black guy does not
want to be called gay he was shook he
did not like that and that's when i
realized oh man i gotta really just you
know pump pump it up you know go as
absurd as possible well absurd [ __ ]
works man i mean honestly you you you're
like you're like the [ __ ] uh the
hottest the hottest ticket right now
in the comments
right dude
look at the humbleness look at the
humbleness on this guy so humble it's
not even humble but dude that's not true
i mean dude a blind squirrel finds a net
every once in a while i'm just i found
my little nut but this is the other
thing is you guys know this is y'all
work hard that's why people want to hate
on you you guys stream all the freaking
time a morning stream a night stream
during the day and that hard work pays
off you get out what you put in and i'm
not doing this to kiss you there here
but those other people that want to sit
on the sideline and hate they don't put
in one 100th of the effort that you put
in you know and i'm not even saying that
you guys could probably put in more
effort but you guys grind it out and
that's why you're successful and that's
why people hate it so i'm not trying to
say you're perfect but you guys are
doing really good and that's why they
hate you is because nobody wants to
actually put in the work and if you do i
think i'm an example of it if you go and
stream you go and film content and yeah
it's going to be cringe it's not going
to work at first and you're going to
embarrass yourself sometimes but that's
part of it that's why you're putting
yourself on camera that's why you're
being vulnerable these other people
would never do it that's why they hide
behind a screen name that you'll never
see their face because they're all real
cowards it takes a man to be able to put
themselves out there and be vulnerable
and try to entertain others yeah i'll
give you this man you know talk about
you
people say whatever they want about alex
but it talks about putting himself out
there you have done some of the wildest
[ __ ] that i have seen and here but you
have to just think if we work hard and
we really really like you know put our
noses to the grindstone we we might lose
out to a job from the guys from mob deep
someday oh that would be all right man
they're going to replace rotc with the
tooth from bob deep
yeah but i can't believe you all know
peter gunza yeah he took my job or he
got the job and i was devastated and
that guy from shooters like you just do
your own podcast and i started talking
to a microphone and so everybody here
you know all these people they want to
do it and they actually get fans you can
there's people that you know they get
their weird little fans and you can
support yourself doing it even if you
suck at this sadly um but a lot of
people what i'm trying to say is they
don't want to put in the effort they
don't want to actually get on press
record press live it takes a lot of
balls and cones to do that but people
don't and that's well you know what
after they hit they sit on the sidelines
and hey have you tried the young turks
approach which get a bunch of money from
dn from from a bunch of dnc ngos get
like millions of dollars yeah bro get
some that comet ping pong pizza money
and i love how the yet [ __ ] it's always
self-made young turks i'm like hillary
clinton literally gave you money go [ __ ]
yourself
and hassan [ __ ] is the worst guy in the
world him and his stream or the ethan
klein
bro forget let me tell you something
even forget hassan piker's politics for
a second i even push he's he's an idiot
with all that i put but first i decided
he just looks like a [ __ ] douchebag
like i don't know any other way oh cause
i don't know if you know this or not
he's a douchebag he looks like every one
of every one of those chicks it's like i
could change him i could just he's one
of those dudes that you you see a hot
drink like why are you with him i don't
know i just feel like i could change him
you notice how they'll push him up in
the uh algorithm and like that vouch guy
up in the algorithm
but they'll try to silence like jimmy
dore and they'll push him down in the
algorithm like i never see jimmy dore
really trending anymore on twitter
because they hate him but they'll push
vouch and like anybody that's like y'all
you have a hundred thousand dollar car
but i'm a communist and i want to lower
the age of consent you're like all right
we'll push you up in the algorithm but
jimmy dore is like yeah i got hurt by
the vaccine they're like you shut the
[ __ ] up right now [ __ ] mouth
piece of [ __ ] and he's like but i got
the facts
no dude you know that hassan [ __ ] i
don't even follow him and every single
time he tweets it somehow in my feed i'm
like i don't even follow this guy i
think i even had him muted and i got his
tweets on my feet i'm like what the [ __ ]
this is the coordinated attack alex
muted him and then he started getting
[ __ ] mysterious letters in his
mailbox of just printed out hassan biker
tweets
he's like come on man just leave me
alone
he's just getting it in like junk mail
in his mailbox every day i don't even
understand i don't even understand what
a douche bro he's so cool what a [ __ ]
douchebag what a [ __ ] douchebag but
he's just like i don't understand
understand this thing because there's
some people like there are some even
some lefties that i'm like i completely
disagree with them but you're like oh
but okay they're funny right oh but
they're entertaining right you go okay
hey i get it like i get why people think
this person is funny i don't agree with
them right
but
then you look he's not funny he's not
smart
i don't understa is it because he looks
like he's he's like the village in new
york the person like i don't get it
yeah i mean i like i said i've watched
so little of his streams but i mean his
commentary the stuff i've seen it's not
like he's witty it's not funny it's
almost like anti-humor but i think they
do think he's funny so yeah i do i you
you i have no idea i can't even
articulate myself i have no idea how he
has such a big following when he sits
there and watching master chef like i
get reaction content but i think it's
just because he's he's live so much
maybe they just have a home for the chat
room you know what i mean people like to
be in the chat so i think it's just he
built a community it doesn't matter how
shitty or untalented he is yeah i mean
but that's [ __ ] youtube but you go to
youtube right now and you see what they
push i mean like merc said like or like
on twitter like you said they push what
they want like i've always thought about
this because twitter's always like we
want this to be a respectful thing bro
alex have you not noticed now twitter's
twitter's new thing when you're on there
now they show you like recommended
tweets of people you don't follow and
they're always tweets of people that
piss you off like it's never tweets you
agree with like i recommend a teacher
like oh wow that guy i'm gonna follow
that guy it's always like robert reich
or whatever i don't follow him and it's
always a recommended people because
because you follow politics here's this
guy telling you why you're not allowed
to have guns i'm like oh so you don't
want us to fight but yeah you do want us
to fight of course you want us to fight
oh you did you like trump you're going
to love the lincoln
project like no no no no no no no no
well that's that's a social engineering
because of course they're pumping up the
legacy and media that they like like
that's not even a conspiracy they they
admit it but but really it truly like
according to this expert that was on
msnbc he said even with all that even
with him trying to help the left the
right still even the more conservative
channels and accounts still get more
viewers even with the shadow banning
even with all the books yeah